This song is one of Thomas' favorites,
called "What You Do with What You've Got."
♫ You must know someone like him ♫
♫ He was tall and strong and lean ♫
♫ With a body like a greyhound ♫
♫ and a mind so sharp and keen ♫
♫ But his heart, just like laurel ♫
♫ grew twisted around itself ♫
♫ Till almost everything he did ♫
♫ brought pain to someone else ♫
♫ It's not just what you're born with ♫
♫ It's what you choose to bear ♫
♫ It's not how big your share is ♫
♫ It's how much you can share ♫
♫ It's not the fights you dreamed of ♫
♫ It's those you really fought ♫
♫ It's not what you've been given ♫
♫ It's what you do with what you've got ♫
♫ What's the use of two strong legs ♫
♫ if you only run away? ♫
♫ And what's the use of the finest voice ♫
♫ if you've nothing good to say? ♫
♫ What's the use of strength and muscle ♫
♫ if you only push and shove? ♫
♫ And what's the use of two good ears ♫
♫ if you can't hear those you love? ♫
♫ What's the use of two strong legs ♫
♫ if you only run away? ♫
♫ And what's the use of the finest voice ♫
♫ if you've nothing good to say? ♫
♫ What's the use of strength and muscle ♫
♫ if you only push and shove? ♫
♫ And what's the use of two good ears ♫
♫ if you can't hear those you love? ♫
♫ Between those who use their neighbors ♫
♫ and those who use the cane ♫
♫ Between those in constant power ♫
♫ and those in constant pain ♫
♫ Between those who run to glory ♫
♫ and those who cannot run ♫
♫ Tell me which ones are the cripples ♫
♫ and which ones touch the sun ♫
♫ Which ones touch the sun ♫
(Applause) Thank you very much.